moi ce que simplement je voulais lui
dire et vous avez coupé rement où je lui
dis c'est un peu comme loana parfois tu
me met mal à l'aise en tant que
maintenant et je veux dire une chose
facile à là quand vous parlez de ça je
vous dirais que je chéris les rappeurs
là bas j'ai peur ça va chose je te
reposer ce compositeur j'ai fait trois
albums à chaque fois que les gens sont
dans la merde ils m'appellent pour un
record d'audience je suis parti à los
angeles et moi parler est-ce que là je
suis pas au tribunal et faire mon procès
je suis venu parce que j'aime bien s'il
j'aime bien mal reçue contre moi
j'allais rentrer cette fois qu'on vous
savez quand vous avez fait trois albums
que vous écrivez composer et peggy votre
musique etc à chaque fois vous faites un
record d'audience et vous remplissez le
théâtre trévise en promotion sans appel
frais séquelles jean paul gaultier qui
vient vous voir ou des grands
réalisateurs ne comparez pas à quelqu'un
qui n'a jamais rien fait à qui on a tout
servi sur un plat ok je savais la même
tenue je me tenu qu'un roumanoff mais ça
donne pas parlé
mais moi j'adore alors maintenant si je
l'adoré parce qu'à la vie en rouge au
sujet à danger permet de se mettre là
[Applaudissements]
non
alors si haut placé au poids la descente
je vais te rangi
je trouve que tu gagnerais à en faire un
peu moins parce qu'il est éclatant et
se finir ouais je sais ce que c'est que
de monter ce que je ne ferai jamais
montés sur une scène à prendre du texte
à voir des gens face de toi je sais que
c'est dur et j'ai grand respect bonsu
qu'ils font à bab ont déjà un fils un
peu gentil on
sait que bon je vois par exemple comment
tu traites les followers ou les twittos
ce que tu rigoles quoi j'ai a mis au
point mais promotion ta carrière tu
entends la france
et ceux de la vérité mais écoute
commence avec des calculs de ce genre là
parce qu'on écoute donc quoi mais j'ai
rien à prouver ce que j'ai fait mais
moins nombreux alors la droite la fiche
wikipédia bon allez pas trafiqué
l'aliène est venu vers moi j'aimerais
bien que les biens soient trafic et le
jour je me suis mariée de trois cancers
bon alors elle aurait alors et donc dont
un est donc non
ce que j'aimerais c'est le côté de vous
sans dents ça mange pas
je pense que tu vous identifier
alors oui mais on montre à la télé le
hockey mais boîte un coup c'est parce
que j'ai une robe qui glisse en accord
alors dites moi
c'est incroyable mais je suis toujours
les faits narrés
écouter déjà
des gens qu'on justement on fait un peu
de trucs dans leur vie tu vois peut-être
que tu devrais dire tiens ça a l'air dur
mais mine de rien j'apprends des choses
parce que c'est pas ce qui te fait toute
la journée qu'ils disent des choses
vraies tu vois bien le dire c'est
parfois aussi qu'elle ressent actions
les gens que toi je suis chiant tout
d'un coup là-bas dieu maintenant
mesdames
vous entends écoutez moi bien je vous
entends je vous écoute oui je fais
quarante huit heures vous existez
exister grâce à moi elle m'a laissée aux
bons
le jour où
on va pas recommencer comme il ya
écoutez moi écoutez moi je vous ai
écoutés moi je vous ai écoutés mais
aussi le film moi je vous ai écoutés
m'écouter moi j'ai bien écouté les
conseils de quelqu'un qui me remplit mon
frigo qui me book qui quoi qu'ayant
d'information le bon bout au jour
d'aujourd'hui je fais le centre ceinture
voilà bonjour bonjour au jour
d'aujourd'hui je fais tout toute seule
et je rempli le théâtre et et certains
concerts que ce soit en allemagne ou au
poste nous allons en annonçant promotion
rtl tf1 absolument c'est bien toute
seule
normalement sur les hormones afida sans
promoteur alors moi je veux bien vous
écouter vous plaît on fait un déjeuner
malheur pointu monnaies hoyaux mars est
ce si vous aviez un conseil font de
faire un chef et il faut promouvoir
sinon alain guilbaud fort que moi où tu
sais pas ce que tous les soirs le
théâtre trévise et plat en vélo
fais toi c'est la vérité je suis la bd